good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock we are live from my hometown of
wigan again this morning you're very
welcome to join us on day two of our
week of special coverage looking at the
cost of living crisis and how it's
impacting the good people of wigan this
morning we have some exclusive polling
to bring you that makes for bleak
reading about how people are struggling
so much they're not heating or eating
their homes today we're at my old
primary school beach hill where we'll be
talking to the teachers and families at
the breakfast club as the governor of
the bank of england warns we're heading
for apocalyptic food prices i'm going to
be chatting to the northern ireland
secretary brandon lewis shortly plus the
shadow work and pension secretary
jonathan ashworth and the mayor of
greater manchester andy burnham he's
also going to be here to take a few
questions from the parents here here
it's tuesday the 17th of may
skipping meals turning off the heating
and 84 percent of people worried about
the next six months we reveal the
exclusive sky news data polling on the
cost of living crisis
pension of poverty we meet godfrey and
jeanette who've worked hard all their
lives and now can't even afford hot
water or heating i don't think we'll
survive
another winter winter
getting by together we visit a mosque to
hear how its community is faring amid
soaring living costs
never too early for a pint of beer is it
we're live at a brewery in wigan having
to adapt through the cost of living
crisis
and we'll be joined by some local sports
stars from the wigan warriors who'll be
showing us their skills here at the
school plus this fun chat wiggins
football mascot krusty the pie
[Music]
and we're heading back to the 80s
bringing you more of the very best music
that's homegrown here in lancashire
also coming up on the programme for you
wherever you're watching us around the
world this morning
i'm in ukraine as hundreds of fighters
are evacuated from the azov style steel
works in mariupol as a siege that lasted
more than 82 days seem to be coming to
an end
addressing the protocol and addressing
northern ireland's troubled past i'm a
stormont as the government tables
legislation on two fronts in a bid to
restore power sharing
[Music]
good morning everybody live from wigan
the uk is in the midst of a cost of
living crisis and this morning we can
bring you some exclusive data
commissioned by sky news which reveals
the extent to which people are
struggling and it makes for very stark
reading we're going to be putting those
questions to the minister in just a
moment this weekend we're going to find
out how people in this town are being
impacted here at my old primary school
at beach hill it's been rebuilt since i
was here 50 years ago let me tell you
nearly half of the kids are on free
school meals
over 2000 people we surveyed across
britain
more than four in five eighty four
percent say they are concerned by the
rising cost of living over the next six
months
sixty-five percent of people has
switched off their heating to uh lower
their bills we're told 27 say they have
skipped meals as they can't afford to
eat and more than half that's 52 percent
are socializing less 44 of people are
also driving less than they did before
with 31 percent working from home more
to save cash
almost a third are cutting back on tv
and streaming to reduce costs and one in
five people 19
have even borrowed money to make ends
meet well the northern ireland secretary
brandon lewis is with us now mr lewis
thank you for joining us on the
programme this morning thank you very
much indeed uh let's start with our
exclusive polling should we uh 76 of all
voters 71 7 out of 10 tory voters do not
think that this government is doing
enough to help them uh in these
incredibly challenging times with the
cost of living your thoughts on that
this morning secretary of state
well one of the things i see is a
constituency mp as members of parliament
across country will see some of the
challenges that our constituents are
facing
and we all have energy uh prices that we
deal with whether it's heating our own
homes and talking to our constituents
about the challenges they face so i
absolutely recognize that that challenge
that people are seeing out there i have
to it's why the chancellor the prime
minister put in place that big package
just a few weeks ago in reality about 22
billion package some wishes already come
into place with the changes that came
through in april we've also got more
changes coming through that threshold
change for national insurance it's going
to make
people better off that comes through in
july as well as the further support for
energy later this year but as the
chancellor said we do recognize this as
a challenge and that's why he keeps
these things under review so that we can
look at what can we do and do as much as
we can as i think we've shown through
covet as a government we're prepared to
do to help people where the government
can recognizing that this is a really
big global challenge that we are seeing
around the world
we're hearing from action for children
they're telling us that at least one
child that they know of i'm sure there
are others
had chill planes so
the house couldn't be heated enough he
couldn't go to school because this cat
this kid had chill planes
well nobody wants to hear that kind of
challenge we all want to ensure that
people can look after themselves their
families children and
and other members of their family and
indeed our wider communities and as i
say that's why we've put in place this
package reforms we've got including the
reduction in fuel duty one of the
challenges actually with the issues
we're facing northern is not everything
the chancellor did could be transferred
to support people in northern ireland
due to the protocol but we want to do
what we can to support people but there
is a global pressure on energy prices
we've seen that we understand that but
as a government we will continue to look
at what we can do and the chancellor
does keep these things under review but
as i say there is a 22 billion pound
package of support already in place some
of which
comes further into into support for
people in july this year
and what do you say
to people who say this party this
government is just completely out of
touch we interviewed one of your
colleagues yesterday from the home
office two million people have viewed
her comments online so far when she told
me yesterday morning that people should
either work longer hours or get a better
job that is not to understand the
challenges that some people in britain
face this morning
well as i said i think we do recognize
those challenges not just as a
government but all of us as constituency
mps and people with friends and family
who we talk to all the time and
understand what those challenges are i
think the point the ratio to be fair if
you look at the wider interview and what
rachel's outlining is as a government we
are looking to develop an economy that
allows better paid jobs more
productivity we're seeing more people in
work even than we saw before kovid but i
absolutely understand and accept that
doesn't move away from the challenges
that people are facing today uh the
challenge we're seeing globally we're
not the only country in the world
dealing with this issue
and that's something the chance as i say
does keep under view and we have put in
place a substantial package of support
22 billion pounds worth and i would say
if you look at our track record through
the challenging times we had through
kovid where we put that huge amount of
support in whether it's the furlough
scheme and support for businesses among
other things i think we have got a good
track record of doing everything we can
to soften some of these challenges that
people face and i know the prime
minister is determined to continue to
look at these things with the chancellor
to do everything we can
how can somebody who's working for the
nhs where we all went outside to applaud
for them because of the incredible work
that they were doing during the pandemic
how can we ask them to work even longer
hours which is what the minister was
suggesting yesterday
well as i say i think if you look at the
wider interview and the whole of what
she was outlining yesterday what rachel
was outlining was this work that we are
doing through big investments and
support for people making
development to ensure that we get a
higher productivity economy more jobs
available we have got more people in
work than we had even before covered so
there's more opportunity for people out
there that's part of his showing we put
more money in people's pockets as well
as this huge package of support that the
chancellor has put in place but that
doesn't shy away from the challenges
people okay around the world we
understand that
not my question minister my question is
how can people who are already working
their fingers to the bone for the nhs to
keep us as healthy as we possibly can be
and to look after us when we're sick how
can we ask them to work even more hours
which is exactly what the minister said
yesterday
well look as i say i think
to be fair i think what rachel was
outlined it was a wider issue across the
economy for people not a particular area
and look what we are doing for people
who are should work more hours minister
yes but she's talking across the whole
economy yes but she's talking across the
whole economy and us making available
for people those opportunities obviously
quite right okay in some industries and
in some sectors people will already be
working very long hours
for the jobs that they do whether it's
in the public sector or elsewhere and
that's why we've put in this it's a
package of support the 22 billion pounds
of support to help people so that they
are paying obviously we've got that
reduction in the threshold for national
insurance that will help people with
hundreds of pounds a year the reduction
in fuel duty all of these changes we are
making doing what we can to ensure that
people have more money in their pocket
to deal with these global challenges
that we're seeing well it's not working
minister it's not working are the poor
just not working hard enough is that
what we're telling them
no it's not what i'm saying at all in
fact if you look at what i've just said
it's quite the opposite we absolutely
recognize how hard people are working
across the economy with more people in
work than we had before kobe that's why
the chance was put in place a 22 billion
pound package of support to help
individuals we're also putting in
support through that system that we've
that i've outlined already to
help companies uh develop more jobs for
those who want them and those who need
them and we are always keeping these
things under view as we do through kobe
this is a global challenge it's
something the chancellor has already
said that he is very focused on he will
continue to keep under views we do at
all times to look at what more we can do
through the course this year where it is
appropriate where the government can
afford to do that to help people as i
say i think our track record over the
last few years have put it in support
wherever we can and however we can is a
good one and i think that does show that
we are determined to help people where
we can and in any way that we can
um dr liam fox calling for the treasury
committee to launch an investigation
into why the bank of england so
comprehensively in his words
underestimated the inflationary threat
to the uk do you agree with that
well i'm not the bank of england is
quite rightly independent it will remain
independent what the treasury select
committee do is it's a matter of them to
look at select committees look at a
whole range of things so i'm not going
to call the independence of the bank of
england what i would say um is that of
course we are seeing a pressure on
inflation around the world we're still
in the uk below the us pretty much in
line with what we're seeing across
europe actually slightly below europe as
a whole but that doesn't shy away from
the reality of the pressures that higher
inflation is putting on people and on
people's pockets and as i say that's
something that chance i know is focused
on that's why we've put this package of
support in there while we are seeing
this global pressure on inflation
how helpful is it for the uh governor of
the bank of england andrew bailey to use
words like apocalyptic when he's talking
about a global food shortage who does
that help
well as i say i think look what the bank
leaders and independent body say is
obviously a matter for them i think we
all recognize there is this pressure and
a challenge i think as the governor
outlined yesterday we also particularly
see
pressures on food due to the war in
ukraine and putin's invasion of ukraine
because ukraine is such a big uh
producer of certain products that go
through into the agricultural industry
in the food sector more generally that
is something that the whole world is is
feeling the side effects from and we are
conscious of that as i say that's why
there is a pact of support out there and
it's why we're looking to do everything
we can as we move forward and these
things don't happen overnight but that's
why the chancellor's put packages in
there and the business secretary
and defer as well department of food and
rural affairs to support more food
security for the uk as we go forward as
well
yeah but when i heard a word like
apocalyptic yesterday
i thought goodness me and i can afford
to feed my family what did you think
when you you heard the wood
well i think it does outline the kind of
what they obviously recognize as a and
they see as a challenge for the future
as i say i was somewhat surprised to see
that particular turner phrase because
obviously we can all see that uh prices
can can move we've seen over the last
few months prices can move one way or
another relatively speedily but we will
be doing what we can to put that support
in there as i say for people across the
country we do recognize there's a
challenge this is not a straightforward
challenge to deal with it's a global
challenge
but it is one that i know the chance is
very very focused on no i understand i
understand but you know somewhat
surprised i mean that's an
understatement for people here in wigan
who can't put afford to put food in
their kids bellies at the best of times
another being told by this big geezer in
in london that food um the shortage of
food is going to be apocalyptic
well it's uh it's not i can't answer for
the bankrupting is independent what
andrew um outlined as the governor of
the bank think about that i'm asking you
about the word
you ask me what i think of what he said
it is a matter for the bankers
it's not for me to comment on what they
said other than say yes i was surprised
to see that kind of terminology there
particularly in light of the fact that
obviously food supplies are for
supermarkets one of the things i know
again from the work we're doing on the
north line of protocol is supermarkets
food suppliers are ordered and bought a
long way in advance so supermarkets are
already now placing orders for many many
months down the line for certain
products and they're working on today's
prices and what they're buying for today
is what we will be seeing in the
supermarkets in the period ahead as i
say when i'm dealing with supermarkets i
have to say at the moment their main
focus is around how they move products
from great britain to northern ireland
but as i say we are very very conscious
of the challenges that people are facing
both in the uh energy prices that we're
seeing when people are uh whether it's
filling up their car or filling up their
oil tank if they're on oil at home as
they are in most of my part of the world
in norfolk
we are conscious of that and as i say
that's why that package of support is
there and we will continue to do what we
can uh while dealing with this global
challenge
okay well let's try another one see if
you're more comfortable commenting on
this one draconian that was the word
that the prime minister used yesterday
when he went to northern ireland you're
brief of course he says that he didn't
think the northern ireland protocol
would be implemented in such a draconian
way
um your view on that and what his trip
achieved yesterday
well it was it was a
really good trip it was good to have the
prime minister yesterday we met with
five of the party leaders he also
obviously was visiting thailand who have
played such an important part in belfast
through that playing its part in
supporting the efforts of the amazing
people of ukraine
uh as well as visiting the jewish
communities we had a very good visit
yesterday talking to all the party
leaders about getting storm on back up
and running getting a speaker elected in
the first instance and getting the full
executive upper money is obviously where
my focus is and what we were talking
about yesterday the prime minister is
absolutely right in what he outlined
around the eu the implementation that
they're using and that they want to see
and let's remember what he's arguing for
at the moment is to have more
restrictions than we even have today in
northern ireland with the protocol that
just doesn't work it doesn't work for
business it doesn't work for anybody in
northern ireland and one thing that all
of the party leaders were
unanimous about yesterday is what the
protocol needs to be fixed there are
problems with the protocol and we are
determined to do what we need to do to
do that preferably by agreement with the
european union
just to clarify have you pulled back
from introducing legislation to
override the protocol we're hearing the
latest from liz trust saying that it'll
happen in the summer
we've always said that we hold nothing
off the table we keep everything on the
table to make sure that we can do what
we need to do to ensure the people in
northern ireland have the same rights
and access to goods as anybody else
anywhere in the united kingdom at the
moment the eu are
requiring these checks to be put onto
goods that are not going into the eu we
absolutely respect and always will the
need for checks for products that are
moving into the eu but they're doing it
for products at the moment they want to
go further with products that are not
moving into the eu that just doesn't
work it's not acceptable we have
challenges already uh we've obviously
got challenges with getting installment
up and running around the protocol with
the unionist community all the unionist
leaders having issues with the protocol
and all leaders of all parties wanting
parts of protocol resolved and fixed so
that's something that they're unanimous
about so we take nothing off the table
we would like to get an agreement with
the eu but the foreign secretary will be
setting out later today further details
around the next steps for us
is that a yes
well it's a yes in that we take nothing
off the table and as i say we've got a
cabinet meeting in just an hour or so a
couple of hours time and the foreign
secretary will be setting out the our
next steps on how we deal with these
issues for the people of northern
ireland and the wider uk because over
200 businesses in great britain now not
supplying northern ireland due to the
protocols this is something affects
everybody and we want to make sure we
resolve that and the foreign sector will
be setting out as i say following the
cabinet discussion today those details
later today
but that's not going to happen this week
because we were led to believe last week
that this week that uh parts of the
protocol were going to be um um i was
gonna say got rid of i was gonna say rip
shop you probably use that say that was
evocative language but the protocol was
likely to be changed this week that's
what all the mood music was suggesting
having been to northern ireland the
prime minister are we saying now that
potentially that is not going to happen
until the summer at least until well
something like that this week was never
uh on the cards we're still debating the
queen's speech and we won't finish
debating the queen's speech and voting
on that a little bit later this week
later tomorrow so that was in that sense
that was never on the cards what we've
always said is that we will not take
anything off the table we would do what
we need to do to ensure that products
can move to northern ireland in the way
they should be able to move to northern
ireland from great britain as part of
the united kingdom's eternal market
something the protocol itself says it
will respect that at the moment is not
working properly we would like to do
that by agreeing with the eu but as i
say we we reserve the right to do what
we need to do to do the right thing for
the people of northern ireland and the
wider united kingdom
before i let you go secretary of state
um i thought for the good people of
wigan this morning and this school where
i
was first educated 50 years ago this is
where you say i don't look this
old
well it's great to be able to speak it's
always good i know to be able to go back
and visit a school you went to before
and see how it's changed i've done that
myself recently and it's always slightly
surreal to walk around even if they've
changed a lot those uh those hallways
that we walked around some years ago not
that long ago to be fair but um
and i know that it's it's always uh
as i say an interesting thing to see how
things move on and it's really good to
be able to see
people around the country having that
opportunity through shows like this and
what you're doing carrying your team to
express the experiences they're having
and that's something i think is
important that all of us across the uk
can learn from what each other
experiencing and seeing in our local
communities
okay it's great to talk to you thanks
very much indeed for joining us
secretary of state always a pleasure
thank you
i was just indicating to uh mrs mccarthy
who's the head teacher here at beach
hill community primary school to sit
down because we're ready we're just
winding up the minister
i'm sure that's not true how are you i'm
grant thank you you could sit there
rather than here and then we could get
there we go and then i can see you a bit
better there we go hi morning good
morning how are we doing good excellent
excellent who we got um
we've got malaika and we've got bathroom
fantastic and this is breakfast club
excellent what do we like for breakfast
club what do we eat bagels
toasted bagels
oh we're not gonna get much words out of
you this morning are we
not until they're third
tell me about breakfast club well it's
something it's an initiative that we
started about four years ago as part of
the national school's breakfast scheme
and we were subsidised for a long time
by the magic breakfast program
and so we don't just invite children
into our breakfast club we invite our
families as well we understand that it
can be chaotic of a morning trying to
get families ready for school
so we have invited everybody just to
take the strain off everybody else in in
the family home okay and so everybody's
welcome we get preschoolers coming and
we get
past pupils who will swing by and pick
up a bagel on the way to the high school
down the road oh really yeah okay
and now the funding for that has run out
although we do subscribe to get a
reduced rate on on food at the minute
it's just how long we can keep that
going with the and what does it make a
huge difference it it's an opportunity
at the start of a day for the community
to get together to have a chat with
myself other teachers the pastoral lead
about anything that they might
have concerns about an opportunity for
families to sit together
and just a way to start the day so that
children are fed and they go to class
happy and ready to learn what difference
does it make if a kid has an empty tummy
when they come to school okay you know
yourself when you're hungry it's almost
impossible to do anything effectively so
it's difficult to think it's difficult
to drive it's difficult to do anything
so that's why we've put huge emphasis
over the last four years i'm making sure
that families are fed before they come
into class okay now um what about
preschool meals is there still a stigma
attached that i had free school meals
and my sister when we were little dad
lost his job only for a short time but
you know we did and there was a huge
stigma attached to that we had to eat
our meals separately to the rest
everybody else got fed first and then
those that were on free school meals got
fed afterwards what was it like now it's
not quite so cruel these days okay um
nobody knows who receives free school
meals anymore um
but what we have noticed over the course
of the last two years as people have
lost their job due to the pandemic
that more and more families are becoming
eligible for free school meals um
but there is no stigma attached because
nobody frankly knows who's on pre-school
meals and who isn't okay what what is it
like forty percent i don't know we're
running at about 48 wow half of the kids
nearly half yes yeah wow okay and is
there enough funding for that
well the we do get people premium grant
to support those children who are
eligible for for free school meals
but it doesn't go
far enough to give them the support that
they need
okay tell me this is not the school i
remember i mean it's on the side of
where i went to school but my school was
small i mean it was a fantastic school
don't get me wrong i learned 12 times
table here do you know yours
no but we're going to say yeah just say
yeah yeah 612's are 72 aren't they yes
they are okay yes they are and and
strong values as well you know which is
as um
stood me in very good stage throughout
my career what about what are you
teaching the kids here well as you say
new building so it's opened about 11
years ago um and probably very similar
values to the ones that you learnt here
okay we are trying to teach our children
to be um
resourceful resilient uh make a positive
contribution to the community in which
they live um and to be tolerant of all
faiths all creeds all all beliefs okay
are you contemporaries to stay here for
the show
what if i said no well i was upset
you're more than welcome you're more
than welcome thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot and just to say that we
will be chatting uh later on we can
warriors uh are going to be uh coming
along to oh i've spoiled the surprise
i'm so sorry and krusty the pie is
coming too how cool is that going to be
she's got a poker face hasn't she
there's a poker face
yeah let's take you through where we'll
be for the rest of the week as well
today as i said here at beach hill
community primary school joining in
their breakfast club and then on
wednesday morning we'll be at the brick
tomorrow a local food bank providing for
those who are struggling
with the most with rising food prices
and then on thursday morning we'll be
here in a family-run bakery taking a
look at how local businesses are faring
in the face of rising prices and fewer
customers
notice i said fewer rather than less
because that's what i was taught here
now we heard yesterday the government
minister rachel mclean suggesting that
working more hours and moving to better
paid jobs is the route out of long-term
poverty
but what about those in retirement still
struggling to pay the bills katarina
vachacci spoke to two wigan-based
pensioners who are barely getting by and
fear what's to come this winter
godfrey and jeanette ward have worked
hard all their lives to afford their own
home
now retired their pensions can't stretch
to cover their rising bills or do urgent
repairs like their broken boiler how
much would it be to get a new one that's
it
i think i said about 2 000 if we paid
cash for one which we can't afford you
can't afford it
so no hot water no heating that's
correct
so where do you go you know when you
want a shower or a bath um across the
road uh she has a shower and a bath
and she's told me i can go
anytime i want
but you don't like troubling them do you
really
things have become too much for them to
cope with they keep just one room warm
with an electric fan heater that's
expensive to run
jeanette had pneumonia twice over winter
we've had two
bad winters
and luckily we've got through it
but
like jeanette says
i don't think we'll
survive
another winter winter
money
is the main thing
i don't like asking for things
if i if i can't afford it
you won't get it forget it
so i think it will be
a home
no
for
for us both no
but we don't want that
a weekly lunch club run by age uk is at
least a chance to sit in a warm room and
have a hot meal
as prices go up their weekly food shop
is getting smaller
only have one more meal
and lots of tea time
sometimes i go to the chipper
and so sometimes i go to the pie shop
so
and even for a pie now with greenhouse
it's 2.50 or more
we're trying my best to cope
it's not easy
the couple say that without each other
they couldn't bear this
a life after work that's now so full of
worry
so full of fear
catherine of autopsy sky news in wigan
okay we've got some breaking news
figures for you helena is here with me
in the old sports hall hi tell me in the
old sports also we've had labour force
data today kate and there's there's lots
in there as you know employment
unemployment workers wages uh how many
people have jobs all that sort of thing
the thing we're really interested in uh
today given the cost of living crisis
that we're all facing is what's
happening to wages and crucially are
they keeping up with this massive rate
of inflation that we're seeing
essentially
the money that people being paid keeping
up with the cost of everything and the
short answer unfortunately is no so for
the fourth month in a row now real wages
which is what they are when you compare
them to inflation are falling so down
1.2 percent uh really quite a
significant fall given that tomorrow
we're expecting inflation data and we're
expecting uh inflation to exceed nine
percent so a huge huge disparity and
that's what matters doesn't it because
you know if wages are keeping up with
inflation there's a degree to which
people in work can cope with the kind of
rising cost of living particularly worth
noting okay given that we're in your old
school that actually public sector pay
really lagging behind the private sector
as well really significantly lagging
behind so that will affect teachers
doctors and nurses and all these people
that we're talking about just one other
thing i just want to point out that's in
this data as well vacancies we've spoken
a lot about how many jobs are available
for the first time on record there is
now more vacancies in the economy than
there are unemployed people and that
might sound like good news if you're
looking for a job but it's yet one more
thing that pushes up that rate of
inflation you know companies have to
offer higher wages to get those few
people in pass that price onto customers
just a quick thought before i let you go
very quickly apocalyptic the word
apocalyptic thought on what the minister
said there yeah
really uh he was took some pushing
didn't he to comment on that uh words
from the governor of the bank of england
apocalypse we have to put this in
context he doesn't normally use language
that is that inflammatory it's not
really his job his job is to keep calm
his job is to you know keep uh sort of
certainly keep inflation under control
just worth saying one other thing he
said yesterday is that he wanted uh to
ask people again to try not to ask for
pay rises and that's a sort of straight
out of economics textbooks really if you
ask for pay rises it goes up with
inflation they're worried about what's
called a wage price fire while
everything spirals out of control but
you know people facing real problems in
their lives you say how can i not ask
you doing the math so i know that i've
got to stop you third so we can fit
everything in thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot and you look like you've
got your school uniform
exactly
yeah that was clever it's not just
thrown together isn't it thanks a lot
thanks a lot looking at some other news
for you now here on the program and uh
we're hearing that more than 260
ukrainian soldiers have left the as of
style steelworks in mariopol after an
assault that's lasted 82 days the troops
had fought on even after the rest of the
city fell to russian forces and the
battle had become an important symbol of
resistance president zielenski said it
was
the defenders negotiating in exchange
for captured russian soldiers
thanks to the actions of the ukrainian
military the armed forces of ukraine
intelligence as well as the negotiating
team the international committee of the
red cross and the un we hope that we
will be able to save the lives of our
guys
this morning hello to you um dominic so
what happens next
okay 264 men have been evacuated from
the steelworks 53 to a town in the
russian-controlled eastern part of
ukraine where they're going to be
treated in a medical facility a russian
hospital
and the others
are thought to be on their way to
ukraine proper some conflicting reports
as to whether they are still in the
russian control but every crane or
they've been exchanged or passed over in
through a humanitarian corridor into
ukraine itself uh as you hear there the
president of ukraine saying that they're
going to be exchanged for russian
prisoners not quite clear yet as to how
that's going to happen and what isn't
clear is what's going to happen to those
men still left behind and how many of
them
they there are their commander says that
their mission has been accomplished she
says that mission was to buy time to
hold down what he says were 20 000
russian soldiers attacking their steel
works in this titanic struggle between
them and the besieged the small besieged
and beleaguered garrison inside the
steel works they will now be free to
fight elsewhere but of course for the
relatives of these men it's been a
horrendous ordeal we spoke to some of
the mothers and wives one of them told
us that in her head she didn't think she
was going to see her husband again in
her heart she hoped she would we've been
in correspondence with her this morning
she still doesn't know if her husband's
got out yet so for her the i guess the
anguish goes on for now at least
okay thank you thanks a lot dominic
let's see how that story pans out such
brave men now the government set out
plans for legislation to rewrite
northern ireland's post-brexit trading
arrangements the prime minister
describes it as an insurance in case
negotiations with the european union uh
to amend the protocol failed david is
standing by for us in belfast what was
achieved yesterday david
and that's a good question and brandon
lewis in the last half hour has
confirmed to uk that the government's
simply going to set out its intentions
today but the dup have consistently said
they need actions not words so one
senior toury mp is telling me this could
be a strategic disaster simply angering
the eu without achieving the restoration
of power sharing in northern ireland the
brandon lewis will also today table the
government's
legislation on how to deal with northern
ireland's troubled past effectively
giving victims of violence a choice
between pursuing truth or pursuing
justice and they're asking why they have
to make that choice i don't think that's
going to satisfy british army veterans
either who were anticipating an amnesty
so an awful lot of northern ireland
business in the house uh today as well
as that visit to northern ireland by the
prime minister yesterday i'm not sure
it's achieved very much
okay for now david thanks so much indeed
thanks a lot uh we're here uh in the
sports hall of beech hill primary school
this morning continuing our week-long
coverage on the cost of living crisis
that affects towns like my hometown of
wigan you might just be able to pick out
there at the back of his head that is
the mayor of greater manchester and we
will be speaking to him in just a few
moments time before that though
yesterday india and i went to uh the
local mosque to catch up with some of
the local uh people there and ask them
about the impact of the cost of living
crisis here's what they had to say
when i lived in wigan
this
was a local primary school actually here
in wesley mays 35 years on and it's now
actually a hugely important building for
the muslim community it is the local
mosque over 2 000 muslims in wigan that
usually rely on it okay very important
how important massively particularly in
the cost of living crisis it's a place
of safe haven for them okay now go
inside let's go thank you
we've got people from all sorts of
backgrounds coming to the masjid right
from refugees
and
right all the way to doctors and all who
work in the infirmary
and everyone is is sort of like you know
impacted uh by the cost of living uh
crisis one thing that i like about wigan
is that there's the diversity in the
muslims and the people that come from
different backgrounds have increased so
the population has increased massively
so there's not more any like stereotypes
anymore and a lot of things have
improved so
it really helps and it increases those
chances and opportunities for other
young people you wear a hijab but also a
blue peter badge doesn't matter where
you come from
or how you look like or your scarf
it's just your actions and the way you
inspire people is what matters most it's
really hard affect me and affect all my
colleagues as well the taxi driver it is
very very difficult difficult for
everyone
not just me and for
all other sectors as well we did have
little projects
in the mosque as for food and any
families who really struggle we are
trying to get a lot of
[Music]
family gatherings and
and social network
so that we can communicate and help each
other
this is elsie she's uh doing the bagels
uh for the kids this morning they're all
sat here look nice and quietly
morning
oh i bet you're not this quiet when
there's not a tv crew here are you
what's your name you look cheeky chloe
chloe how old are you chloe 11 11 you
look 12. um have you had your breakfast
a bagel in there was it nice yeah what
about the rest of you okay yeah
what's your name
oh you look cheeky what's your name i do
isaac how old are you i said six six are
you what do you think about school
of course yeah what do you like best
english english that's impressive what
about you um
in school pe when i when i used to ask
my little boy what do you like best he
used to say lunch
yeah those are the only laughs to get
from seven-year-olds but there we are
adam care with the cable bashing as we
go backwards because uh somebody who's
like me not been at school for a while
i'm sure he won't mind me saying that is
the mayor of greater manchester andy
vernon morning morning nice to see you
back home oh yeah
yeah i feel like you're enjoying it i am
i am hi ladies we're going to chat to
you as well what do you make of what the
minister said yesterday oh my goodness
um
the idea that people can just uh oh get
more hours it's easy they're actually
working all hours at godsends anyway or
get a better job i mean it's just not in
the real world if you talk to people in
this this area um and then you got the
fellow last week saying oh 30p is fine
if they just learn to cook properly
um it's one after another and they
haven't got a handle on what's going on
now in people's homes and people's lives
yeah so they've got a chance today to
support a windfall tax which i think
they should so they can do something for
everyone's energy goals
but i would say to them just you know
get that uplift and universal credit
back give people something now for those
who are most struggling it just looks to
me like they are just just flailing
around trying to blame the public in
some way or lecture the public it's just
wrong there's no money tree though you
know is what they would say if i was
trying to defend the government i would
say you know what are they going to do
they've only got a finite amount of cash
but these are exceptional times and you
can't so when they get the money from
people in your poll today what is it two
in five people say they're skipping
meals yeah yeah what what's the health
impact of that or you know for kids uh
if they're doing that sometimes you just
have to step in and help people but they
say no money tree the energy companies
are making massive profits you know
windfall level profits why not support a
win full tax today in the house of
commons labor a right to bring that vote
today and all parties should back it
that lady's nodding here i know you
could you'll take some questions right
yes
just tell us your name so that people
i'm jill jill and i do quite a bit of
chatting around the community and two of
the things that came up this week when i
mentioned that you were coming was
around the greener
thorn
and also the thirteen percent that were
paired to you know for to have a mirror
and i suppose in town like this we're
talking about this this crisis that
we've got
what is the actual impact that you can
have on either of those things if you're
out of time so on the clean air zone i
absolutely understand what you're saying
this was something that government asked
us to do we had no choice we had to do
something about uh air quality because
we've got problems in certain places
it's a gate it's breaching the law you
know and obviously that impacts on kids
health however we tried
and then when all of the issues hit with
the
cost of living situation we're dealing
with we recognized it was unworkable and
we went back to the government earlier
this year and said that it's unworkable
and we've now proposed to the government
a non-charging clean air zone what that
means is for those who want to upgrade
their vehicle they will get help to
upgrade their vehicle but it won't be
done by charging everybody that well
that's what we've proposed and we're
waiting to hear from the government on
my role my brother i can't understand
what you're saying but let me just give
you a direct example about how i think i
can help you
and people across the wigan borough
where i live as well i have taken the
decision to put buses here back under
public control we've had 35 years 26
years it's total
free-for-all with the private bus
companies charging what they like
i'm gonna introduce in wigan next year a
two pound cap on adult bus fares uh and
that i think will make a real difference
to people
and you've got a question haven't you
yeah this is i'm angela angela i am part
of northern netherlands
i just want to start with a quote from
john tronto who says that when we
understand ker we'll have to redefine
democracy
and the basic of any good society
that understands kurt is that everybody
has enough and everybody can afford to
pay the bills and what we seem to be
stuck in is this political system
whereby we have the tories you take away
and then labor we sometimes overserve
and to get through that then we've got
to find different ways of working
together and stop that wealth extraction
that is enabling power companies to have
it over the barrel
questionnaire
and also look at how we shift resource
directly to families our own gbi so when
your role is murder
across greater manchester outside that
political system what can we do to
increase and encourage community power
and community welfare first on the big
book about the political system i am
absolutely clear westminster
doesn't work it's dysfunctional it
doesn't work for the north of england i
think the westminster system that we've
had has created the north south divide
to be honest so some if you're going to
close that something fundamentally
different is needed and i personally
would support
proportional representation
for the commons to create a different
way of working
between the parties on your specific
universal basic income is ubi
i think this is an idea whose time has
come why
you know you all know and and i know
living here over the years people living
in this area the wigan borough have had
to kind of take on more and more
insecurity when it comes to their work
you know the culture of
zero hours casual hours people doing
three jobs and then they're spending
every hour worrying because they won't
be able to get the rent you know so
they're living on the edge and that
damages people's people's health a
universal basic income would put a solid
foundation beneath everybody so they
could have a life with security it's not
worrying about everything you know we've
come out through a kobe pandemic but
we've got a mental health pandemic now
haven't we because so many people
are living so close to the edge all of
the time and we've got to take that away
and give them much more uh much more
security in their everyday everyday
lives and a universal basic income would
do that and we'd stop spending so much
money picking up the pieces of failure
because you've set people up to succeed
rather than the benefit system which is
constantly in my views trying to trip
them up and make them fail ladies i'm
going to have to steal the mayor away
and we've got another question on the
other table if you don't mind thanks
very much thanks a lot can you go that
way mr mayor and just sit towards the
end of that table now we're just going
to move that lady on the end can we just
sit there if you don't mind
thanks very much and this lovely let you
find there you find them this lovely
lady's got a question for you mr mayor
yes just here what's your name my name
is edda adam what's your question ada my
question is
for price rising
chris rising how do i how do you
experience to cope with this crisis
honestly i i hear it everywhere i go i
was in salford a couple of weeks ago and
a food bank there said to me that
they're not giving out frozen food
anymore because everyone's turned their
freezers off you know because anything
that's got ongoing energy
yeah so
it's real and it's happening now
i would say to the government they've
got to do something now stop making
excuses stop blaming the public that 20
pound uplift in universal credit that we
had during the pandemic should come back
and come back straight away because
people are struggling right now and you
know we can't have this thing the
minister's coming on to kay's program
saying oh work more hours or get better
did you hear the minute to say that
yesterday what was your thought on that
yes but yeah yeah
tell me what the difference 20 pounds
would make to you it's going to help
because like me as a single parents i'm
working hard to try to make up
everything and if they bring that 10
pounds it's go a long way
yeah i mean i i just think they should
should do that they've not
to me got a grip on the situation at the
moment it's it's changing now for people
isn't it with the prices and
cost of energy i would do the universal
credit uplift now giving help to those
most needed and then the windfall tax
which they should also do would help
everybody with their energy bills ahead
of october and i think those are two
things that they could announce now that
would take away a lot of the worry
from people who are just now thinking
how am i going to get through this year
okay i'm afraid we're out of time
hopefully that was useful
we really appreciate you taking the time
thanks very much we'll leave you to it
and we'll hopefully see you again soon
you will thanks a lot thanks a lot thank
you ladies just squeezing by you guys
i'm so sorry adam thanks a lot thanks
bear with us one second mr mayor if you
would well yesterday um actually on the
program a government minister suggesting
people as we're just saying they're
struggling with bills could work more
hours or get a higher paying job to help
them out in the long term i asked the
northern ireland sector this morning
about the comments he told me the
government recognized people in certain
sectors are working very hard
people will already be working very long
hours uh but for for the jobs that they
do whether it's in the public sector or
elsewhere and that's why we've put in
this it's a package of support the 22
billion pounds of support to help people
so that they are paying obviously we've
got that reduction in the threshold for
national insurance that will help people
with hundreds of pounds a year the
reduction in fuel duty all of these
changes we are making doing what we can
to ensure that people have more money in
their pocket to deal with these global
challenges that we're seeing well it's
not working minister it's not working
are the poor just not working hard
enough is that what we're telling them
no it's not what i'm saying at all if in
fact if you look at what i've just said
it's quite the opposite we absolutely
recognize how hard people are working
across the economy with more people in
work than we had before kobe that's why
the chance was put in place a 22 billion
pound package of support to help
individuals
tomorrow's your thoughts on what the
minister is saying tomorrow morning
perhaps a bit of damage limitation we
absolutely recognize that people are
working very hard and a lot of people
can't get better paid jobs or take on
more hours after the comments of his
colleague yesterday but on that question
of whether the government is going to
give people more support as our poll
exclusive poll this morning suggests
that almost everybody thinks they should
75 of voters
clearly they are still casting around
for ideas because brandon lewis said in
july people will get a bit of a tax cut
but that is because when everyone's
national insurance went up at the
beginning of april to pay for the nhs
and social care the chancellor also
announced that he understood that would
be tough and therefore he would increase
the threshold which people paid national
insurance to 12 000 pounds from around 9
000 pounds so it will be a tax hike and
then there will be a bit of a tax cut on
that so it's not a tax cut compared to
where we were in march so yes there will
be a bit of relief on that people will
pay higher taxes for three months and
then they'll go down a bit if you are on
the lowest incomes but and you won't pay
at all if you're on the lowest incomes
but you know there is an acknowledgement
there i think that a lot of people are
really struggling and he said that all
options would be on the table for the
government to step in further okay
tomorrow thanks very much indeed
tomorrow's take later on meantime don
draper who co-founded tax and the family
campaign um he is joining us now to talk
about this in more detail um hi don
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning um your thoughts first of
all on what we heard from the minister
yesterday oh if only it was that so easy
um for the five million plus families
who are on universal credit
working more
will make very little difference to
their family budgets
earning more they have to pay more
income tax they pause you just
pay more nifc national insurance
contributions as you've just heard and
they will lose some of their universal
credit
when you add all that together the state
will take back 70
percent of any new money they earn
for example
if they need an extra 100 pounds
they will earn
an extra 100 pounds
the only difference with making their
family budget would be only 30 pounds a
mere 30 pounds
at the minimum wage of 9.50 this means
that they have to work over 10 hours or
two days a week simply to increase the
weekly budget by 30 pounds
for millions of people who are caught in
this
tax trap
earning more is sadly not the answer
normal bringing forward the basic rate
cutting the basic rate of income tax
which i hear that some ministers are
arguing for
we know that children on lower income
do less well so why are we i ask why do
we ask we go on pushing people more more
people
in into benefits into poverty
because of our income tax system
that dates back to 1990 when some of the
people we've just been some of the moms
we've just been talking to hearing from
wouldn't probably even be at school
themselves
that system needs to change we we need
to stop taking money away
from people who are
in dire straits okay
okay john
yeah
thanks you make excellent points there
don thank you so much for joining us
thanks a lot
um adam we can see that breakfast clubs
are in properly in full swing now um
this is uh something that happens every
single day ahead of the kids starting
school uh full belly we're hearing from
the head teacher is what these kids need
in order to be able to learn properly nz
is standing by for us this morning where
are you lindsay
uh at a brewery not quite breakfast club
but uh a pint of beer can happen any
time of the day surely we are at this
200 year old building in wigan just off
uh the town center down this very
cobbled road i'll take you inside and
we're going to get a sense of how
businesses in wigan are impacted by the
cost of living crisis of course the
pandemic as well as uh uh brexit causing
huge problems for businesses i'm
bringing martin the managing director uh
at the brew house here um just give us a
sense of what the cost of living
like for you as a business in wigan
for the moment in time um cost of uh
products have increased by 15 percent
yeah so we've managed to absorb that
cost um we put our price up a couple
months ago but the biggest problem we
see now is the electricity cost um
we had a good deal it which ends in end
of august it was a five-year deal but
now we're expected uh our prices to
increase by 300
wow which is a massive increase uh what
will that do to you as a business i do
not want you i don't know um it's a bit
of a worry really uh we just got to
absorb those costs and then probably
next year come into
increasing prices but you've just got to
be careful how much you increase those
prices by and there's a larger knocking
effect in there martin because people
might not have the expenditure to to
come out by beer you know to go out and
have a drink it's a bit of a luxury is
that a worry for you as well to factor
all that in
it is yeah i mean obviously prices are
already increased um the big breweries
put their prices in by march so you're
looking at five and ten percent they
generally only increase their prices
once a year so i can't see the prices of
beer
going up until at least again next year
march april but inflation hurts as well
yes it does martin thank you so much
appreciate your time here we're going to
be exploring uh the whole brewery a bit
later on there's four different levels
here and different stages of how they
actually make uh some lovely tasting
beer good being a good muslim boy i
can't taste it but cameraman nathan i'm
sure uh we'll be filling his boots this
morning back to uk
okay thanks very much indeed inzi and so
i thought that you'd want to have a chat
with some more of the kids i'm coming
down what's your name
belle that's a lovely name how old are
you bill nye are you what did you ask me
before they came back to me
i only get nervous speaking to nine year
olds
what's your name
emilia and how old are you here and
what's it like being at school here and
i like roots because there's a lot of
nice challenges there are a lot of nice
teachers what's your favorite subject
spin around this way and then adam can
see you round we go there we go
english
english was my favorite subject at
school as well did you know i used to go
here
this was my school
what do you think of that
cool cool what do you want to do when
you leave school
i want to be a carer for all people
[Applause]
oh she's one
she's one yep she's one today absolutely
she is let's go around this way as well
can i talk to you too
great can i come down here
come this way look this way look that
way and then we can see adam's there if
you look down that camera do you want to
wave to your mum dad
morning what do you want to do when you
leave school
i don't know you don't know yet what's
your favorite subject
lovely what about you what's your name
um
ocean
what a cool name that is what do you
want to do do you know yet um
i think i want to be a beautiful
american a beauty therapist and that
that's because you've got such beautiful
hair that you've got planted here does
mom do that for you or does dad do it no
i didn't you did it oh adam look how
beautiful bring your head forward and we
can see
there you go beautiful what's your how
old are you intent
fantastic i'm going to let you finish
your breakfast anybody else wants to
talk to us how about you you look
naughty
look this way and then you can adam can
see you there we go what's your name
henry
henley what a great name how old are you
11 and what's your favorite subject
i knew you were going to say sport are
you a good footballer
rugby should i tell you who's coming
later on wigan warriors
yeah they are
yeah they really are i knew that you
knew that no you didn't oh yeah maybe
you did maybe you did okay you're
looking forward to that oh yeah okay
fantastic i talked to you all a bit
later on
just come this way because i just want
to show here that this is what people do
can i just drag this across here elsa
there you go this is what the kids
have and they are allowed to come into
school seven o'clock in the morning 7 30
come and have their breakfast
full belly means they can learn better
continuing coverage from my old school
in a couple of minutes here on skype
[Music]
[Music]
you